monkey pox is unfortunately exploding
new york city has declared a state of
emergency and the right continues to
repeat homophobic tropes to try to
dismiss
this one also i mean listen
they'll just any public health concern
they will dismiss
uh if possible with whatever
justification they can find
with covid it was it's the china virus
and it's not really dangerous and the
masks don't work and they want to take
our freedoms or whatever with monkey pox
it's basically
it's a gay disease it's a gay sexually
transmitted disease this is what they're
going with because it appears as though
the very early handful of cases
were in gay men and of course it has
gone well beyond that now and it's quite
frankly an incredibly irresponsible
distraction to be focusing on that but
we will get to that so a bunch of
different things going on daily beast
report it may be too late to stop monkey
pox becoming endemic in the u.s and
europe
we failed to get on top of the monkey
pox outbreak and we may have missed the
chance to stop the disease becoming
endemic and a permanent threat in the
u.s and europe monkey pox is spreading
fast all over the world especially in
the united states and europe with cases
doubling every two weeks there's a
growing risk that monkey pox will become
a permanent problem in countries where
before outbreaks were rare and small the
pox is in other words close to becoming
endemic in a lot of new places if this
happens it might become very difficult
to eradicate
monkey pox causes a fever and rash is
fatal in a small number of cases will
become yet another disease that people
have to worry about all the time there
are two paths to endemicity if the virus
infects enough people fast enough to
outpace efforts to trace transmission
and vaccinate
it could become endemic in people
the good news is that this kind of
endemicity doesn't have to be permanent
it's hard but possible to reverse it but
monkey pox was originally a zoonotic
animal virus it circulates in rodent and
monkey species in western central africa
where outbreaks in humans are frequent
if the pox finds a new home in some
animal species in north america or
europe could be squirrels rats or
prairie dogs it will be all but
impossible to eradicate regionally
meanwhile new york city has declared a
monkey pox state of emergency mayor eric
adams has declared a state of emergency
due to monkey pox the city estimates 150
000 people
mostly men who have sex with other men
are at risk the city has more than 1200
reported cases about 25 percent of all
the cases in the u.s
and continues to see the numbers rise
in terms of the vaccines the city is
facing a shortage of monkey pox vaccines
with appointments filling up minutes
after they're released the city expects
to get 80 000
monkey pox vaccine doses in the coming
days now there are some like marjorie
taylor green and others who are mocking
the entire thing calling it a scam
saying it is a sexually transmitted
disease that only threatens a specific
group of people
she says laugh at it mock it reject it
of course monkey pox is a threat to some
people in our population but we know
what causes it and and that's pretty
much um
it's it's basically a sexually
transmitted disease
uh so it's not a threat to
to most of the population and so it's
not a global pandemic it's really not
and people just have to have to laugh at
it mock it and and reject it this is
exactly how uh covid to some degree
covet much more contagious became what
it did i mean remember
matt gates laughed at it early in the
pandemic matt gates put on this enormous
gas mask and went on the house floor and
it was all a big joke
and then we know how that all went and
if this is only a sexually transmitted
disease that affects gay men
why do kids now have it well it was only
a matter of time it was only a matter of
time it spreads through contact of all
kinds and if an adult who's infected
picks up their kid
their kid can end up with monkey pox so
this is a very serious situation
not a shock
that republicans are again laughing off
another public health concern
will they ever learn
find me on twitter at deepakman and let
me know we're going to take a very quick
break much more coming up today glad
you're with us